Military Support or further provocation
both Germany and the United States have
confirmed that they will begin sending
tanks to Ukraine to help in the battle
against Russia comes 11 months after
President Putin began his invasion or as
he called it his special operation in
Ukraine
these are the leopard two tanks that
will soon arrive on Ukrainian soil
courtesy of Germany in while the United
States have committed to send 31 of
their Abrams tax Russia says the
decision is extremely dangerous and
takes the conflict to a new level for
some it's a step too far others would
argue it's what's needed to add further
pressure on Vladimir Putin
well tonight on our special program
we'll be discussing whether sending more
weapons to Ukraine could help bring
about an end to the war or if the
opposite could happen we'll also be
answering your questions with a panel of
experts and hear from the president of
Ukraine Vladimir zielinski who was
speaking exclusively to Sky News when he
was told that Germany would be sending
him tanks but first these are some of
the key moments of the day we will also
deliver battle tanks to Ukraine leopard
two tanks that is the result of very
close and intense discussions with our
partners with our allies
we will train Ukrainian troops here we
will make Logistics available
maintenance and we will also allow
partner countries to deliver these tanks
last week I announced that we would gift
many battle tanks as part of the next
major package of UK support to Ukraine
and I'm pleased that our friends and
allies are preparing to follow our lead
Russia is planning for new offensives
they are building heavily up they are
mobilized hundreds of thousands of new
troops ramping or production acquiring
ammunition from authoritarian regimes
like Iran
North Korea and and uh and therefore we
have to be prepared for a new Russian
offensives that's exactly why the
announcements made last week are so
important with more armor more
ammunitions more also long-range
weapons like the high Mars but also the
new announcements of Battle Tanks so
it's urgent and that's the reason why I
welcome those important announcements
today I'm announcing that the United
States will be sending 31 Abram tanks to
Ukraine the equivalent of one Ukrainian
Battalion secretary Austin has
recommended this step because it will
enhance the Ukraine's capacity to defend
its territory and Achieve his strategic
objectives the Abram's tanks are the
most capable tanks in the world they're
also extremely complex to operate and
maintain
so we're also giving Ukraine the parts
and equipment necessary to effectively
sustain these tanks on the battlefield
and we began we'll begin to train the
Ukrainian troops on these issues of
sustainment logistics and maintenance
soon as possible
well after these announcements let me
take you through which countries are now
supplying Ukraine with tanks and
Chancellor Schultz of Germany said his
government has approved the delivery of
those leopard two tanks to Ukraine which
is the first step to providing 14 of
them from Germany's military stocks the
United States has announced that pledge
to supply 31 of its Abrams Tanks
initially and the UK you'll remember was
the first country to provide tanks to
Ukraine offering 14 Challenger 2 tanks
the Netherlands Finland and Spain have
also announced their willingness to
provide tanks to Ukraine but haven't
announced that
well Ukraine has of course reacted
positively to NATO allies providing
further military support and Sky's K
Burley was actually interviewing
President Vladimir zielinski at the
moment that he found out that more
German tanks were on the way
leopard two tanks are coming from Europe
you must be relieved
uh shiny
ah Sona
um
no
thank you anymore
[Music]
the carcasses of Russian tanks litter
this square but reports suggest that
Putin is regrouping for a new offensive
this spring join me for an exclusive
interview with President zielinski here
in cave on Sky News
well the White House is National
Security adviser John Kirby tells guy
news that Ukraine would receive all the
support it needs along with the tanks
it's going to be many months before
these tanks are actually delivered to
Ukraine but we're not going to waste
time we're going to get some training
going for Ukrainian tanker soldiers uh
here just as soon as we can I mean the
Pentagon is working on those plans right
now and we're also going to help the
ukrainians build in the kind of
logistics and supply chain needs that
they're going to require to be able to
field these tanks they're the most
sophisticated tanks uh uh in the world
there is a supply chain uh unique system
that has to be provided to keep them
running to keep them operational we're
going to use the time available to us to
make sure that the ukrainians are ready
to receive them so that when they get on
the ground the ukrainians can they can
go we saw a great a terrific
Announcement by Germany a significant
announcement today that they are going
to be providing uh and working with
allies to provide two Ukrainian
Battalion tank battalions uh to uh to to
the country so these leopard tanks that
the Germans have they are there on the
continent they are more available they
are certainly going to be very effective
inside Ukrainian lines and they'll be
able to flesh those out those
contributions out sooner than the Abrams
will be able to arrive
Usher has responded to the announcements
with our correspondent Diana magnet in
Moscow and from our correspondent
Siobhan Robbins in Berlin but first to
Mark Stone who's in Washington for a
cinder mark it all seems to be happening
now very quickly and in terms of the
sequencing was the German announcement
the key to unlocking the U.S decision
well it's very it's a chicken and egg
one and it's very hard to to ascertain
uh precisely uh the sequence of events
you say that the announcements are
happening quickly yes but the delivery
of the of the tanks uh the American ones
and indeed the European ones well that
will take quite some time uh I've been
speaking to uh John Kirby who you heard
from just then it's clear from him that
the American tanks will take months and
months uh to come and that is largely
because these tanks are not being
delivered from existing U.S army stocks
but they are being procured perhaps from
the manufacturers themselves or even
from other countries to whom the
Americans have sold these tanks there is
a suggestion they may be brought bought
back and then provided to the ukrainians
a very long process in terms of the
American Tax the American assessment on
how long it will take to get the the
European tanks the leopards
um either German or or owned by other
countries well they say the American can
say again that will take some time
months not weeks so yes um the the
decision making has changed very swiftly
it was only just a few days ago that the
Americans were saying no we won't send
our own tanks the Europeans should
provide theirs now um intense diplomacy
that's how it's the phrase that's being
used uh here intense diplomacy has has
unlocked something
um I think one way of looking at it is
that the Americans have done just a
little bit more than a statement of
intent they have said yes we will
deliver tanks but when you when you
drill a bit deeper it's clear that those
tanks will not be coming for quite some
time almost certainly not by the time
this so-called spring offensive the
Russian spring offensive is launched but
the hope of course is that the European
ones well they will come there are all
sorts of issues all sorts of logistical
supply chain issues uh that are wrapped
up in the um in the decision making
being made here in Washington about the
M1 Abrams also in the White House they
discussed uh the issue of of getting of
letting sophisticated technology inside
those Abrams Tanks uh being given to the
Russians if the tanks were to fall
Behind Enemy Lines the M1 Abrams has um
depleted uranium armor which makes it
very very thick impenetrable but that
armor they do not want in the hands of
the Russians so an awful lot of
logistical issues but also diplomatic
issues that are being ironed out but
don't expect to see American tanks on
the battlefield anytime soon Arc many
thanks well to Berlin and Siobhan
Robinson Siobhan everyone there must be
aware and has been agonizing about the
the symbolism of German tanks being used
to fight Russians in Ukraine
yes there was Applause in the parliament
today when Olaf Schultz talked about the
announcement and there's been a lot of
pressure from the opposition to make
some sort of step towards sending uh
leopard two tanks to Ukraine and
internationally outside Russia many of
the Allies have been very supportive of
this move but as you say this is a much
more difficult issue domestically and
when people ask why has there been such
a delay I think we need to look at
several main points so one of them
clearly was this fear that by sending
leopard two tanks this could lead to
some sort of escalation in the war we
heard from the chancellor today saying
that he didn't want Germany to be drawn
into a wider war and that was clearly in
his thinking when he delayed to decide
was this really in the interest of
Germany was this in the interest of NATO
the other thing that sources have been
telling me was playing on his mind was
this idea that they did want some sort
of commitment from America they wanted
the Firepower the military might of the
us behind them and a commitment to send
Abrams even if they're going to take a
while we know those leopard twos are
going to take around three months but
the other big problem was political uh
and public opinion and I was talking to
people on the streets of Berlin today
and it's really interesting because
really the reaction to this is mixed one
person said to me we have to help
Ukraine we can't leave them on their own
but then another lady said to me I'm
really scared this is going to draw us
into a wider War I have a 24 year old
son I don't want him to be called to
fight as a soldier and then finally one
man said to me a view which you were
just talking about there he said we know
what happened when we fought with Russia
in World War II this is going to
escalate he was worried that the next
step could be nuclear war so there are
real fears here and I think it's
important not to underestimate how big a
step this has been for Germany if you
look back 11 months no one would have
foreseen that the chancellor would have
committed to these sorts of heavy
weapons going to Ukraine and you have to
remember these are the first German
battle tanks that will be sent to fight
on a European Battlefield since World
War II okay thank you very much
going down and magnet there and Diana as
we know a furious response from the
Kremlin talking about how this can can
alter there well any idea what the
response will be in terms of on the
battlefield
well I mean I I wouldn't describe the
kremlin's response as Furious because
they've been asked about these tanks for
quite a few days even weeks now uh given
the fact that Europe and especially
Germany were deliberating about this
deployment
um and essentially their response has
been firmly within The Narrative of
um of how they've talked about every
weapons delivery to date and that is
um that this is uh uh uh that reinforces
the narrative that this is a NATO attack
on Russia where Ukraine is a proxy
Battleground and every set of weapons is
just uh more Grist for that Mill
um Dimitri peskov the Kremlin spokesman
said today
um that any new delivery of Tanks would
be burnt burn up just like any other
um I think what will be disappointing
for the Kremlin now is that they can't
point to the dithering in Europe as an
example of cracks or fractures in the
NATO alliance May has once again proven
itself with these announcements to be
remarkably robust and United and I think
that will be a disappointment for the
Kremlin how it reacts on the battlefield
remains to be seen we have been talking
a lot about a possible Russian spring
offensive but I think the other side of
that is of course that the ukrainians
need to be planning
um how to recapture those territories
that Russia now claims as their own
they're in this war of attrition around
bakmut at the moment where are they
going to use those tanks when they
finally arrive in the theater on the
battlefield to maximum effect to try and
punch through Russian lines will that be
down around zapparesia to try and make
some Headway there possibly towards
Crimea or will they continue to use them
around bakmut how much Reserve Fosters
do either of these two sides have at
this stage for a spring offensive but I
think you know the the we may see some
sort of response from Vladimir Putin he
didn't say anything today I'm sure
Dimitri peskov will be asked about it
tomorrow the German Embassy the Russian
Embassy in Berlin has issued a very
robust response pointing to Germany's
World War II responsibility towards
Russia I think that was also it feeds
into Russia's narrative but it's
overblown if you think about the fact
that when the Nazis were pushing at the
Red Army during World War II with
millions of Soviet lives lost a lot of
those lives lost were actually Ukrainian
lives now Germany a very different
entity from Nazi Germany is supporting
Ukraine against Russia to try and
maintain its sovereignty and territorial
integrity and actually when you look at
it that's a very very different thing so
this symbolic idea that I think Germany
sorry Russia will keep hampering on
about that you have German tanks rolling
towards Russian lines again actually
when you look at the sort of
nitty-gritty of that it doesn't really
hold much water magnet in Moscow Siobhan
Robbins in Berlin and Mark Stone in
Washington thank you all very much
well now Ash Von Robbins was saying
there it took Germany quite some time to
come to the decision to send Ukraine
tanks the chair of German parliament's
defense committee tells Sky News that
the country's history was part of the
reason
for many people in jail
it's now for one year ago it's a strange
situation that we deliver weapons it's
always a topic in Germany it's not very
popular to talk about this questions and
so step by step we started delivering
weapons to the Ukraine beside to help in
economic way and and also illuminated
way we delivered many weapons very
effectful we started in in May and I I
know I I visit I visited they will cry
two times that it's very really
effectful but thanks it's always a
special thing and so the chancellor was
waiting to do it together with other
countries the thing is that Germany has
to allow it if you we have 14 countries
in Europe and they use the Lego part
battle tank so Germany has to say yes
you could deliver it and so it sometimes
it needs time but at the end it was I
think it could really a good sign and I
know I have now many people friends in
Ukraine and I know they are really happy
that Germany said okay we will do it
together and now uh also the the United
States will deliver and
Great Britain I think it's a very
important sign uh for uh Vladimir Putin
that he realized that we are
um not only yes but that we do something
the view from the German Parliament uh
so then a busy day of announcements but
how does Ukraine plan to actually use
the tanks it will receive eventually
while retired Air Vice Marshall Sean
Bell has been taking a closer look for
us
tanks will be crucial for any planned
Ukrainian spring offensive modern tanks
such as Leopard 2 and the U.S Abrahams
have high-tech armor to improve
survivability and a very powerful Cannon
which can be fired accurately on the
Move day or night and with a variety of
different ammunition
president zielinski has asked for 300
modern tanks although the M1 Abraham's
tanks is very capable this risks playing
to the Kremlin rhetoric that this war is
a battle between the East and the West
between Russia and U.S led NATO as a
result the U.S was almost certainly Keen
to see The Leopard 2 deployed first
despite historical and constitutional
concerns now that Germany has agreed to
send leopard twos to Ukraine numerous
other countries are likely to also throw
their weights behind zielinski's request
although at this stage the total Falls
well short of the 300 tanks requested we
might expect to see the totals rise over
the coming days
but translating a commitment into
fielded military capability takes time
and transporting these 65-ton tanks
together with their spares ammunition
and support equipment halfway around the
world will take weeks however training
the ukrainians to operate these modern
tanks could take months if Ukraine was
able to liberate experienced tank
experts this chain training could be
achieved more swiftly particularly
exploiting the West's high-tech
simulators
we might expect Ukraine to focus these
valuable assets on their primary
offensive efforts so although they could
be used in the donbass around Bach moot
or further north on the p-66 Russian
resupply lines we should expect them to
be the tip of the sword of any Ukrainian
attack on the land bridge between Crimea
and the donbass
in response Russia has announced that
plans to field its own modern tank the
T14 amata to counter this threat but in
reality the T14 has not yet been used in
battle is available in very limited
numbers and is reported to be very
unreliable
Little Wonder then that Russia has
rumped up its threatening rhetoric over
recent days as they recognize the
decisive role that Western tanks might
play in this war
well it has been an eventful day as you
know we've got a panel of guests here to
answer your questions on how the
decision to send tanks to Ukraine could
affect the war joining me this evening
from Strasbourg Ukrainian and piolena
commandco sits on Ukraine's security
defense and intelligence committee
Hamish to Breton Gordon and fresh from
his efforts with our big screen our
military analysts retired Air Vice
Marshall Sean Bell very good evening to
you all now as I say we've been getting
an awful lot of questions sent in by Sky
News viewers on this a hugely
significant moment in this conflict so
let's get into some of these questions
and see if we can shed any light from
them and uh Elena I'd like you to to
start for us and uh also give us your
reaction the Ukrainian reaction to these
announcements are no long call for and
you want more tanks to follow and indeed
other equipment but the question is this
is this the moment the war changes for
Ukraine and NATO
and their their friends first I would
like to thank uh to thank you uh for uh
this for providing thanks and uh
especially to you to the United Kingdom
uh because United Kingdom is a nice
breaker uh towards today and
answering your question uh if this may
change the the course of the war
uh I would say that uh technical
technically Western tanks are
outperforming Russian tanks on the
performance and battle Management
Systems
however the number is still a problem
to radically change direction from
defensive to offensive our military need
much much more triple or quadruple
number of modern tanks
but still today there is Magic
breakthrough so we are we are grateful
for these and we do not need only thanks
um yeah me and my colleagues are hardly
working uh on the supply of uh fighter
airplanes
uh we hear quite often that supply of
F-16
medium Fighters which present in
European countries uh insufficient
numbers but we have to emphasize that
we're fighting against a technical a
technologically developed enemy and to
counterbalance the application of heavy
235 airplanes we need f-15e Fighters
with large combat reduced and the
ability to act as missile intercept
interceptor
so the existential need and further for
further upscaling of the anti-missile
defense system to protect against
ballistic missiles
okay well I know that my other two
guests wants to come in on that broad
point but we've got an awful lot of
questions and you can address those
points as we go through them and they
are from this specific to the very
general but here's a specific one and uh
Sean Bell you touched on this in your
earlier presentation but just underline
for us the question is how powerful are
these Leopard 2 tanks in comparison to
Russian ones and it's not just about
power it's about armor as well isn't it
it is and I've got to be careful Hamish
is a a tanky but um for a direct
comparison
um most of the Russian t62 t64 t-72
tanks which the ukrainians are also
using are a 60s vintage they've been
around for a long time and they're
they're bulletproof but they're no match
for modern weapons and that's been
witnessed that there are literally
thousands now lying littered over the
battlefields that have been destroyed
during the tank battles modern tanks
even though Leopard 2 Challenger 2 and
Abrahams are 30 to 40 years old the
amount of armor has increased
significantly which makes a much more
survivable but the key thing is the
power of the punch it's the power of
that gun and challenge two is a really
good example where the jar is stabilized
it can be on the run over rough terrain
still fire very accurate rounds a long
distance day or night with a whole
selection of different ammunition and
that's the game changer in this theater
of operation and don't worry I've got
plenty of questions about tanks for for
Hamish as well and indeed on that and
can I add it in there a lot of people
also asking and how quickly will they
actually get there and how quickly can
the crews be trained up
foreign
I think there's a lot of confusion about
this
um when I I spent many thousands of
hours on a challenge of one and
Challenger two my conversion to
Challenger 2 took less than a day you
know these aren't complex like aircrafts
I'm sure when Marshall changed aircraft
it probably took you know many weeks to
convert so I don't think we need to over
complicate it if these tank Crews that
are going to be trained on Leopard 2 and
Challenger 2 are already trained on on
the the t-72 or whatever it shouldn't
take them too long these are not too
complex the Fire Control Systems are
sort of 90s PlayStation technology
you've got three or four buttons that
you need to press in the right
configuration to fire the gun driving a
tank is driving a tank uh keeping them
fit and on the road a lot of this is
plug and play stuff which is well within
the compass of the Ukrainian so I don't
think we should overestimate the ability
to get these things on the road they
travel on trains and we know the network
in in Poland and Ukraine is excellent so
I'm sure if they're available and the
crews can be trained uh we can get them
up to speed and we've seen how effective
the Ukraine military are at fighting
there's not very much I can tell a
Ukrainian tank Battalion commander on
how he should best fight his Battalion
I'm sure he could do that and if we can
give him the wherewithal and these tanks
Challenger 2 and leopard 2 vastly
overmatch
um that tanks are up against uh you know
I I probably a challenging too will take
five or six direct hits from a t-72 and
still keep going t-72 will take one hit
from a challenger and a leopard and
that's it and talk from Russia about
Western tanks Brewing up you know it's
just not going to happen so I think this
is a game changer and just to add you
know my my own regiment the Royal tank
regiment sort of invented Tank Warfare
on the 20 of a November 1917 tanks were
used the first time and broke through
the German lines pushed them back 17
kilometers the biggest advance in the
first world war the Russians are static
fighting like the first world war which
is why I think the Ukrainian should be
delighted and excited the chance to have
maneuver Warfare to break through those
lines as long as they're supported by
all the other elements of combined arms
maneuver this is going to be a pivotal
time but let's not underestimate and put
things in the way for Logistics support
and training I think we just need to
enable the ukrainians to get on with it
and help them as much as we can
fascinating
um this question Sean you take this one
on as well I will NATO's military
technology be at risk if tanks are
captured by Russian forces now of course
both sides capture each other's Vehicles
is that you know people are wondering is
that has that been part of the hesitancy
particularly by the United States with
its super high-tech weapons and does it
apply also to you know aircraft um that
Ukraine is asking for the high-tech
drones that they haven't supplied is is
that part of the reason why they're not
being well that's a great question that
would have a bottle of wine and we could
talk about that for ages um I I think
that the technology angle
um West the technology is the West NASA
metric advantage and it's very rare for
Any Nation to deploy its
state-of-the-art technology it's very
unlikely the US would put its very
latest technology in the hands of the
ukrainians on the battlefield like that
um I mean it's possible but I think the
the question about the fighter jets is
is very different I I do take hamish's
point about
um the tank Crews if their experience
could be quite quick but training
Ukrainian Pilots to fly an F-16 or an
F-15 that that is not simple at all
conversion courses in the in the
military the Royal Air Force would take
six to nine months to convert somebody
and that's with the benefits and they
would pop out of the end of that not
being particularly competent at the
range of Technology that's available to
them so I think there is a it's it's
gradients give somebody a gun it's
pretty simple to use go to a tank it
sounds it's more it's slightly more
difficult an aircraft we're escalating
yet yet another level of complexity it
may just interject there I mean this is
on the symbolism again we've been
talking about German tanks fighting
Russians in Ukraine but also given the
way that President Putin is
characterizing this war within Russia
itself and with their allies around the
world have the Americans been hesitant
about allowing their tanks to be
fighting Russian tanks in Europe well
almost certainly because practically
speaking the Kremlin is painting this as
not about Ukraine it's a battlefield for
East versus West about Russia facing an
american-led NATO and if America was
just a wheel in there's nine thousand of
their tanks available in the world they
could relatively simply give three
percent of those and meet zelensky Zane
300. yeah so to meet the 300
um but almost certainly America wouldn't
want to be seen at the Forefront of
providing this game changing technology
because that just plays to the kremlin's
narrative the um the reason leper2 so
attractive is it's operated by 13
different countries there's over 2 000
available it's a very capable tank and
therefore other nations can spread the
load and Challenger 2 is very capable as
I'm sure Hamish would vouch for but the
numbers it's only operated by herself
and Oman they just aren't the numbers to
provide
um Ukraine with the numbers and I don't
think Ukraine would want to be operating
lots of different types of tanks with
different training requirements
different training support different
Logistics Sport and different ammunition
so I think part of the reluctance for
America was that political reluctance to
be seen at the lead but I suspect we're
still well shorter than 300 that
zelenski's asked for but in the coming
days and weeks I wouldn't be at all
surprised if we see those numbers e-cup
okay well we've got a question here
which I suppose is partly about the
response from the Kremlin from Russia
and any commenco the question is this
does providing tanks and further
increases in Western Aid such as you
were asking for does it significantly
raise the risk of World War III we know
that Kremlin are saying that this is
another dangerous escalation
capabilities defense capabilities
Ukraine has this the smaller the
escalation potential Russia has and for
the long-time Kremlin tried to scare
Europe America and the whole world
with this escalation Intrigue and is as
if Russia could do something
particularly strong in response to
helping Ukraine but time has shown that
this is in a way a blob and from the
first day of full-scale scale War Russia
acts as a terrorist against Ukraine and
the world and Ukrainian cities have
already been burned by occupiers
ukrainians have been brutally killed and
raped and being deported to Russia and
everything that Russia could destabilize
in the world it has already did
therefore now it is necessary to defeat
Russian aggression and do it as soon as
possible so we shouldn't
be we shouldn't fear and we should be
scared of this bluffing and this
threatens
and hey Mr Bratton Gordon um continuing
with that thing this question uh given
the escalation of now supplying Ukraine
with modern Western tanks what is next
and we held from Elena there obviously
aircraft
is that a possibility
well I don't know about that Sean's
probably better answered there but uh
what what is critical is that uh when
the armor goes forward uh and I agree
with President zielinski 300 an Armored
Division is really what he needs to be
able to have a significant impact in
both the Crimea and the donbass but
critical is that these armored forces
are supported with infantry uh with
artillery the high Mars ideally with air
as well air power is critical but again
it doesn't appear that the Russians have
air superiority so talk coming out of
Moscow that their grand attack aircraft
and helicopters again take these tanks
out you know I I just don't get it we we
haven't seen them really having a great
effect thus far of course sophisticated
modern Western aircraft would help but
as Sean said you know that that could be
many many months away I think the fact
that we can get armored forces onto the
ground relatively quickly that will have
the impact because again I I don't think
Russia talking about escalation I don't
really see where they're going to go
they're sort of running out of most
things and and I come from the group who
believe that actually Putin's tactical
nuclear weapons are are unusable for a
whole variety of reasons so can I just
interject there Amy given your expertise
what about something like a chemical or
biological attack
well again I think this is you know
Putin's threat and sort of um these
false flag attacks with biological and
chemical again I think this is bluffing
I can't see how they would have an
impact you know you talk about novichok
and stuff like that that's very Point
sort of capability the nuclear side
again I think these weapons are unusable
it would take Russia too much time to
move them into an area where they could
affect Ukraine and I'm sure NATO and the
West would be able to prevent them
actually being fired so escalation we
hear about Hypersonic missiles and all
the rest of these multi-billion dollar
missiles being fired to take tanks out
again it's just not realistic but I
think the armored Warfare has the key to
unlock things but it's quite ironic of
course you know our own military has
been denuded because we all thought the
next War would be fought in space and in
cyberspace now it would appear that
things are a little bit more like the
status quoante as they were before so I
think the key is timing if we can get
submission combat per hour to the
ukrainians get them trained up then I
think they have the opportunity uh in
this sort of spring offensive or early
summer to unlock the Russians unhinge
them get behind them with this rapid
mobile warfx the other thing about tanks
you know you can move several hundred
miles in a day they have 50 odd rounds
of ammunition potential to take out 50
Russian tanks each single tank and as
we've heard they've got the protection
to do it so this is you know a real
opportunity here and I'd like well I I
hope that Ukraine's been able to get on
with it we don't want to be
prevaricating just to get extra you know
aircraft or whatever so um I think the
chemical biological and nuclear is a
complete sort of dispersion at the
moment okay we shouldn't pay too much
haste to it I just want to bring in Sean
on that a very interesting word you use
there about prevaricating because some
people also asking yes what is next but
you know why not now look at these tanks
if these this announcement had been made
a year ago it would be a very different
Battlefield we're looking at now if the
West if NATO is going to get involved
well then get involved stop arguing
about it give the ukrainians what they
want and what they need I think the
history books will be written about this
whole conflict and it was a real test of
how far do you lean in the early days of
this conflict
um defensive weapons were pretty freely
handed to Ukraine and had a decisive
impact you remember the 40 mile Convoy
outside Kiev and of course the
devastating effects on the armor now
that Ukraine has so bravely fought the
back I mean Russia's given up over 50
percent of the territory that it had
taken the challenge now is Ukraine I
think it's a really inflection point
it's exactly as Hamish said but it's not
just about tanks it's about the West
suddenly going from a defensive posture
of support to actually how do we now
enable Ukraine to push Russia out so in
that sense it is a turning point it's an
inflection Point undoubtedly the
challenge is how do these weapons
actually get used most effectively and I
agree with Hamish I think if you look at
the options for Russia now then largely
their military looks as if it's
culminated it doesn't look as if it's
got anywhere to go they can mobilize
more people but they're not going to
quickly get the the weapons and the
equipment they're mobilizing their
industry but that takes years not days
to solve the problem so it'd be really
interesting over time which generally
speaking Russia will be looking in the
long term here the challenges has the
West got the appetite for the long term
and how do we make these decisions
slightly quicker and give Ukraine the
tools it needs to Prevail okay got
another quick question I notice here on
tanks and we don't seem to have
mentioned this Hamish do you know it's
about France there's is the Leclerc
isn't it um is there now pressure on
France to follow suit and send its tanks
to Ukraine
well I certainly think there's pressure
on France to to send tanks Leclerc is is
yet a another type of tank again hugely
capable similar sort of Firepower
maneuver and Mobility to the challenges
the Abrahams and also the leopard tanks
uh whether that would complicate things
more one would hope perhaps actually
it's it's masses of leopard twos which
as you said earlier on there are
thousands in Europe that are available
to be used so I think morally we want to
hear the French strongly shout for main
battle tanks for the ukrainians whether
Leclerc uh would I mean it would add a
hell of a punch but would add more
complexity as well so I think the key is
in numbers if we if we can get up to you
know 300 main battle tanks I expect
there'll mainly be leopards uh for a
Ukraine that will be decisive that will
allow the Ukraine to have the impact
that we're all hoping for all moral
support from the French the clerks would
would help but might complicate things
as well okay uh well plenty of questions
as we've already had about where this is
all leading and this really is a a big
picture question about a potential peace
deal or how does it all end and Elena
camenko can I can I put this to you the
the question is will any peace deal
between Kiev and Moscow result in Russia
keeping control of Crimea
how far is Ukraine prepared to go to
achieve peace
if you ask any Ukrainian today if he
agrees he or she agrees that
we would
um
we would lose our some of our
territories and
Crimea is considered by all ukrainians
as Ukrainian territory if you ask them
they were definitely everyone would
answer that they don't agree uh to have
the key to have peace on uh this uh
under these conditions so uh we are not
ready
to agree on uh such kind of conditions
consistent line from Ukraine Crimea is
our territory he seized it in 2014
there's no peace talks no peace deal
until it is returned to Ukraine and just
in terms of returning it recapturing it
did the tanks change the equation could
we ultimately see a big tank LED battle
to recapture Crimea yeah there's a
couple of questions in there one of
which I think if the tanks are used to
punch a hole between the sort of land
bridge between Crimea and the donbass it
certainly isolates uh Crimea and does
create a real threat militarily to
Crimea
um I think from historical reasons
without going to the detail Crimea would
be militarily extremely difficult uh to
take but going to your wider points
loads of questions about
um what does winning look like in this
conflict and it's very difficult to see
either side winning in the conventional
sense that both sides will pay a huge
price Ukrainian people the population of
a huge price left of Arc is Russia
sweeps through the whole of Ukraine that
looks really unlikely writer Mark is
that Russia is expelled out of every
corner of the donbass and the Crimea
against practically for a military
perspective looks really difficult so
the real challenge is how does this
conflict get brought to an end and
undoubtedly president zielinski and the
Ukrainian politicians will have a huge
weight of History resting on their
shoulders it's certainly not the right
time now but at some stage this war will
have to end and there will have to be
some sort of very difficult
conversations to enable that to happen
well our next question follows on from
that and hamster Brett and Gordon
um in your honest opinion how many years
do you see the conflict in Ukraine
lasting for well you mentioned the tank
parallel with the the first World War
four years
well I think it's impossible to say I
mean what going back to the previous
discussion one thing I suppose one has
to think about what what is the vital
ground and vital ground militarily is is
ground that is essential to your mission
and if you lose it your mission fails
and you know is Crimea vital ground for
both uh Ukraine and for Russia
um but as far as the longevity uh I
think nobody except the Russians wanted
to go any on any longer than it than it
needs to be which is why it's so vital
that that the West give absolutely
everything they can to ensure that
Ukraine prevails we have prevented
Ukraine for losing now we must enable
them to win what winning looks like I
think only the Ukraine people can tell
us
um and whether that is as Sean says the
right of art with Ukraine retaking
Crimea and the whole of the donbask
going back to the boundaries of 2014
um only Ukraine can answer that but I
think what is key is this show of unity
from the West this show of this Hemi
heavy armor going into Ukraine I'm sure
Putin and the his other people around in
the Kremlin will realize that they're
tired you know think things are numbered
now and they have got to start thinking
seriously of what they go next I don't
think they can escalate much
um they either lose everything or they
start coming to the negotiation table
but it it doesn't seem right at the
moment and you know in my view it's
entirely up to the Ukraine people to
decide what
um they will negotiate over if anything
but I think that's why this tank
announcement today is so key because it
very much tips the balance in favor of
Ukraine and we and I'm sure the Ukraine
people don't want this war to go on any
longer than possible certainly not for
another few years well let's hear that
from the elected representative of the
Ukrainian people who stay with us
tonight Elena kamenco and on that
question about how long the war will
last presumably the Ukrainian people
respond as long as it takes
we
sorry I I'm I apologize I'm just sorry I
have some you you you heard technical
I have some technical problems okay the
question the question is the question is
just let me clarify just just just be
clear with us and send a message here to
all the UK viewers the resolve the iron
resolve of the Ukrainian people to to
see off the Russians
um ukrainians uh they support the peace
plan of uh Vladimir's landscape and the
this plan includes uh 10 steps and until
these 10 steps are fulfilled uh we are
not we do not agree or uh any uh peace
talks or there is no peace without
without these conditions so uh you know
that it's about uh radiation and nuclear
safety
it's about food security
its energy security and uh also we need
to release all prisoners of war and
Deport the return deported persons
also uh we are we need to establish a
special tribunal and prosecute political
and Military leadership of Russia for
the crime of aggression
and uh so until
this is done there will be no uh any
agreements
uh Hamish might be time for our last
question there but uh thank you very
much for that Elena kamenco
um is America's timing or the and indeed
Germany in the UK's timing on this tank
announcement I'll add into this question
is it likely to put push Russia closer
to starting their next offensive given
what we've discussed about how long it
is actually going to take to get these
tanks into theater could the Russians
try to preempt that
well I'm sure you know timing is always
absolutely crucial in in military
operations but it is very clear from
what we've seen of the Russian military
that we have all been surprised how very
poor they are and of course a lot of
their Elite troops and Elite equipment
is now destroyed
um reports of three thousand or so
Russian tanks destroying well obviously
you can't verify that but they have lost
a lot of their Frontline capability
they're having to rely on the mercenary
criminals of the Wagner group to be the
the sort of uh their spare point if you
like of their uh efforts so you know I
think uh I I think Russia is in a really
bad way militarily and uh that we
haven't seen any evidence of Russian
maneuver Warfare uh Sean mentioned that
you know the the assault on Kiev at the
very beginning of this conflict it was
amateurism it was it was almost pathetic
if that that isn't the wrong word to you
so I I don't think the Russians are in
any position to mount any sort of
armored maneuver armored Advance at the
moment they've certainly shown no
capability for it so um yeah I don't see
that happening I think we need to but
the ukrainians will be keeping up the
pressure on those Russian forces uh all
they can do is throw conscripts into the
front and you know some of the horrific
stories we're hearing about in the
donbass where you know hundreds if not
thousands of these recruits who are
given a rifle a day's training and told
to go over the top in sort of first
world war passchendale type activity
um is just shocking horrifically
shocking so yeah I don't think there is
uh they might well try and start some
early offensive but I don't see they've
got the combat power or the capability
all the knowledge to be able to execute
that so that is why it's so crucial that
Ukraine gets its combat power together
you know we led by this uh armor that is
coming from Germany and elsewhere where
enable them to hold off that spring
offensive and then conduct their own
offensive whenever that might be
hopefully
um you know in the near future to push
the Russians back to enable the peace
deal that that of course everybody
ultimately wants sooner rather than
later